we have been hearing a lot about
security index in the world is it
because a lot of people are using it in
use cases is it because you know it's
been used in seduced cases where it
makes it a very liberating you know
target to attack so I think education so
I know there's one major industry right
now that got a huge wake-up call and
they realized that there in one country
their networks for infiltrators price
and all of a sudden they're there their
industry was used to the physical
security to protect themselves but then
they realize wait we're all digital
stuff and now we need to actually pay
attention to this stuff I think it's
just more of an education process if you
look at the security people they've been
saying the same thing for 20 years it's
just now it's that's hitting home more
and more and more I think so um this is
the same issues we've had for the past
20 years I think so on oh no I mean
that's my opinion why it seems more
prevalent now it's just a more awareness
finally the message is finally sinking
in I don't necessarily agree about the
education as much well maybe they're
related it's just the news cycle when it
comes to to technology in general I
think maybe because technology isn't
changing so much anymore
the I'm seeing just the tech news sites
take security issues way more serious
that's true it does so but it's also I
think let's say 10 years ago you
wouldn't even talk about security when
it came to one of those because it just
wasn't an issue yeah but if you do you
you will need physical access to the
machine nobody should have loaded in
Android nobody we talked about 1 million
Android devices vulnerable yeah no
that's part of the the whole PR problem
where we're yeah it sells and you don't
need to really you have a real security
issue it's it's enough if you have
something that you can make a big stink
about yeah so some security issues
aren't as bad as they are made out to be
and some people like in the security
industry I mean we've both complained
about
you'd comment about a loss they are
attention seekers and that they want to
make a logo for your bug that you were
bounced to something and that sometimes
it's not even a big issue at all like
the whole GPG email thing I was the
perfect example there wasn't the problem
and our configuration this odd way it
wasn't the CPG was not properly
encrypting your emails people like
theater in order to drive consulting
stuff like that or they just like
theater and that's the whole yeah make a
website and have a cool logo that's new
in the last year just for one thing and
yeah we've even been spoofed us even
been spoofed it was technically it
wasn't fake but it was seem to be a
pump-and-dump thing yeah exactly you
know how do you feel there but the grace
of God I know it's being dragged who's
been getting lately yeah I've got news
for complaining about stuff about
structure meltdown right so it's the
same exact talk I gave in China and
Japan in public it's been on YouTube its
public but there was actually reporter
in the room who made a sensationalist
headline or somebody made a pretty
headline and I was funny um luckily I
mean it wasn't anything that that none
of us have said in the past I'm saying I
think what you kind of see from the
outside it's not actually what the
community sees internally that much yeah
I mean what we do and also I mean what
we do is also everything in public you
can read I mean people do troll the
mailing list to see what we post and if
you say something bad yeah that's a good
news cycle for a day and certain sites
can get a click or two but I mean the
majority of everything we do is saying
the coach and the players putting a mic
on
professional men baseball managers lapel
when he's cursing at his players but
yeah it's just different too and we also
all are people I've blown up at times
too
you